- This is "Young Couple,"
a lithograph from 1913 by Emil Nolde.
Nolde is known as one of
the leading expressionists,
a loose group of artists
working mostly in Germany
in the early 1900s and 1910s.
They worked to heighten the emotional,
expressive impact of their subjects
by distorting the forms
or exaggerating the color.
Nolde's subject here is the
relationship between the sexes,
and this was a theme throughout his work.
He was looking for themes that would
get to the core of human existence.
It's interesting when you
look at the two figures
what you see, there's a certain
ambiguity in their relationship.
The man is grabbing
the woman by the wrist,
and she sort of recoils almost,
so we're not sure if she's actually really
afraid of him, there's
some kind of threatening
or dangerous situation there,
or if it's just a coy little
game that they're playing.
But what we have here are three variations
of the same lithograph.
A lithograph is made by drawing on a stone
and then being printed.
Nolde worked in a commercial print shop,
so it was a shop that didn't
really work with artists.
He got very, very experimental.
Instead of just having the edition of 112,
he would change the colors in each print.
Within this edition of 112,
there's actually 68
different color variations,
and we're very lucky here at MoMA
that we have three of those
because what it shows you
is how he used the color,
he experimented with it,
each time to create a
different emotional reading.
By 1913, many of the
expressionists like Nolde
were creating their most
powerful, very important works.
And then of course just
a year later in 1914,
the war broke out in Germany.
If the relationships changed,
the subjects changed,
and the mood, which was
often somewhat exuberant
in the early years of expressionism
changed quite a bit after this moment.